So far, we've programmed the computer to keep track of the number of passengers.
Now, say we want the computer to show us how many passengers are on the bus so far.
We know its stored inside this variable called passengers here.
But how do we tell the computer to show us its value?
Remember that print line instruction that we learned earlier?
That's exactly what we need now.
However this time, we want it to show us the value inside that variable.
To do that, we should type in the word passengers but without quotation marks.
Remember that quotation marks are used when we want
to display a message or the word as it is.
But here, we don't want it to display the word passengers itself.
Instead, we want to see the value stored inside that variable.
So, when we type in something inside those parentheses here without the quotation marks,
Java automatically assumes that this is a variable and starts looking for
the value stored inside
that variable and displays it because this is a print line statement.
Which means, if we run this program here,
we get this print output,
six, which happens to be the value of our variable passengers here.
Let's trace this program step by step and
see why the variable passengers ended up with six inside.
This statement here is declaring this variable passengers of
type integer which is basically creating
this empty box that we can store integer variables in it.
The second statement is initializing it to
zero which is basically adding the number zero inside.
Then, the next statement is updating
the variable passengers by adding five to its old value.
Its old value happen to be zero,
so when we add five to zero and update it, it becomes five.
And then the following statement here is subtracting three from
the old value which is five and updating passengers to this result of the subtraction.
So we subtract three from five making it two,
and passengers becomes two.
And then finally, this statement here is subtracting one
and adding five to the old value of passengers which is two, now.
So when we subtract one, it becomes one,
and then we add five, passengers becomes six.
By the time we reach this final statement here,
our variable passengers will have six in it,
and when we print it out,
this is the output that we get.